Advanced Wars OnePlus 2 rebootcamp is a
remake of 2001's Advance Wars and 2003's
Advanced Wars 2 black hole Rising while
the first Advanced Wars hasn't aged as
well as its sequel both games are
nevertheless elevated by reboot camps
robust Suite of game modes the local and
online multiplayer and an intuitive map
editor as a package there's plenty to do
see and unlock and it's all held
together by a fantastic presentation
that evokes Saturday morning cartoons
and colorful board games
foreign
[Music]
the Advanced Wars flavor of turn-based
tactical combat holds up well in its
most rudimentary form two commanding
officers hailing from different
fictional countries move units around a
map to wipe out enemies and capture key
areas each unit however has strengths
and weaknesses that need to be
considered for both individual
firefights and multi-turn campaigns for
example infantry and Mech units are the
only units that can capture cities
airports seaports and bases they are
instrumental in securing Victory but
their movement is limited and they are
weak to just about everything apc's
transport copters and Landers can vary
infantry and Max great distances but
they need the protection of other units
due to their inability to attack of
course the units tasked with this
responsibility also have their own set
of strengths and weaknesses that need to
be considered tanks can be devastating
at close range but long-range Rockets
can make short work of them artillery
can clean up enemies at medium range but
they are useless if at close range
coming to grips with each and every unit
can be a little daunting but reboot Camp
has numerous tutorial missions across
both games many of which cover the same
ground the basics such as commanding
units and capturing cities are handled
in an optional field training menu which
can be accessed in both games however
the first handful of missions in both
campaigns also act as tutorials and run
through the basics of armored Naval and
aerial Warfare these tutorials do a
great job of showing you the strengths
and weaknesses of each unit but a lot of
the same info is covered twice this
means that the early hours of Advanced
Wars 2 black hole Rising can drag on a
bit if you start with the first game
most missions demand Keen tactics
careful resource management and a decent
understanding of how each unit operates
from there you need to balance your
short-term goals alongside your
long-term ones while identifying
potential threats and keeping a close
eye on your enemy submissions give you a
fixed amount of units to work with While
others are dotted with points of
interest interests that allow you to
purchase new units both Mission types
feel very different from one another the
former plays out more like a puzzle
where you have to achieve Victory using
only what's available to you while the
latter feels more free form since you
can invest in any unit you'd like a unit
strength and weaknesses don't account
for everything though and terrain can be
just as important mountains offer Extra
Protection for infantry and mechs while
cities protect and repair land-based
units roads give certain units more
movement range while reefs can obscure
ships and submarines from enemy sight
lines although Superior terrain can't
save an infantry unit from a tank it can
offer just enough protection for the
Infantry to hang on for an extra turn
this makes battles feel a bit more
dynamic as you advance on an enemy or
set up ambushes each country is also
backed by a handful of colorful
commanding officers or CEOs who have
unique passive skills and abilities that
range from powering up units to changing
the weather the CEOs add an extra layer
of depth and unpredictable ability to
combat that forces you to stay on your
toes you could be gaining ground against
Eagle the cunning Co from Green Earth
only for him to activate his lightning
drivability that allows his vehicular
units to move and attack a second time
not all of these CEOs feel balanced in a
multiplayer setting but in the campaign
they do force you to think ahead and
respond effectively when your rival
activates their superpower now what
really ties everything together is its
presentation the cast of CEOs feels as
though it's been lifted right from an
old cartoon and given a Fresh coat of
paint while each unit looks like it's
been Unearthed from the dusty vowels of
a toy chest this is backed by a catchy
energetic score that swings from Rock
and Roll to Jazz
well the fundamentals of Advanced Wars
are strong the first Advanced Wars does
a poor job of making use of all these
mechanics throughout the story you are
introduced to nine different CEOs but
you can only use three for a majority of
the campaign on top of that most
missions are relatively straightforward
to feed all the enemy units capture the
enemy's capital or survive for a certain
number of days the units at your
disposal will differ depending on the
mission but after a while missions start
to get longer and blend together due to
the lack of objective variety by the end
some missions can drag on for hours as
you and your opponent get locked into a
battle of attrition where no one faction
can gain any significant ground the lack
of a proper rewind feature something
that has become popular in modern
strategy game design also means that if
you make a mistake Sometimes the best
course of action is to restart the
battle which could cost you hours over
the duration of the campaign you can
correct minor Mistakes by resetting your
turn in the menu but resetting a turn
can't save you from a tactical error you
made a few turns back this makes it
risky to try out different strategies or
experiment with different units while
Advanced Wars 2 occasionally suffers
from the same issue the campaign itself
is excellent it improves upon Advanced
Wars in almost every way there's more
Mission variety you are constantly
trying out different CEOs and the map
design is much better at encouraging you
to try out different units and mechanics
one of my favorite missions has you
defend your capital from an onslaught of
enemy tanks and infantry you are
outgunned and outnumbered and because
the capital is surrounded by mountains
most of your units can even access it
this means you must indirectly cut down
the enemy before a unit reaches the
capital
it's a thrilling Skirmish that requires
you to quickly assess threats carefully
position your units and manage your
resources not every mission is as good
as this one but many of them come pretty
close fortunately you can skip a right
to Advanced Wars 2 if you'd like the
game will advise you not to due to story
spoilers but the plots of both games are
unremarkable there's a bit of dialogue
before and after each battle as well as
a couple cutscenes but the combat is the
main event and since it really hits its
stride in black hole Rising I don't
think you'd Miss much by skipping the
first game altogether especially since
both games kick off with the tutorial
and the difficulty ramps up at a similar
Pace as you play through the campaign
you learn coins that can be spent at
hachi's shop in the main menu here you
can purchase music from the excellent
soundtrack artwork and new battle maps
and CEOs that can be used in some of
reboot Camp's additional modes one of
the standout modes for this is local
multiplayer you can play with multiple
consoles via local connection or you can
play on one console by by passing the
controller this is where Advanced Wars
really leans into the board game
Aesthetics gathering around a TV with
friends passing the controller back and
forth as everyone vies for control feels
like the way Advanced Wars was meant to
be played there are dozens of
multiplayer maps and a bunch of cos to
keep combat fresh for each battle so
multiplayer does have some longevity
there's even a great map editor that
lets you create and share fully
functioning maps in minutes the sharing
capabilities are pretty limited though
allowing you to only share with your
friends online plays similarly with up
to two players however the lack of an
asynchronous multiplayer mode it seems
like a huge missed opportunity battles
can drag on as turns get longer and
longer and without that communal feel of
local multiplayer it can be painfully
slow a mode that allows you and your
friends to take turns at your leisure
would have been perfect for this style
of turn-based combat what makes Advanced
Wars OnePlus 2 reboot Camp an exciting
prospect today is the same as what made
the game's compelling when they were
first released fun and approachable
strategic gameplay that is built on a
solid foundation while the first title
certainly shows its age in the latter
stages the moments of magic that earned
Advanced Wars a passionate fan base are
still there if turn-based tactical
combat is your thing then there is
plenty to sink your teeth into here
[Music]
foreign